allora abbiamo fatto queste skype room
per chi non sapesse cosa ne skype roma è
praticamente una stanza dove ti ci
mettono dentro insieme a dei tuoi amici
è in tot di tempo in questo caso 60
minuti per uscire nella stanza sono
nascosti vari indizi per sbloccare porte
aprire i lucchetti trovare indizi per
aprire poi la porta finale per uscire
dalla stanza
io l'ho fatta con i miei amici quindi
dovevamo trovare indizi per uscire però
il tutto era in una stanza horror
completamente horror e ogni tanto
uscivano degli spettri degli zombie che
erano attori veri travestiti dagli
armadi dalle casseforti usciva nelle
mani
abbiamo registrato questa cosa nel
montaggio non vedrete fantasmi mani che
escono dalle dalle porte robe del genere
perché ho voluto evitare di spoilerare
l'escape room mercato come ci volesse
andare e non capirete gli indovinelli
che stiamo risolvendo perché non voglio
spoilerarvi voi guardatevi solo le
nostre reazioni di tanto in tanto e
quello che è divertente
spero che video vi piace buona visione
adesso perché poi quando giochi non è
che guardini guarda dritto come se
stesso
quando di me
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vuoi un bello sta prigione ci vediamo
tra 60 minuti se già fa figlio il tempo
squadre occhio
aprite le cose fatte abbiamo vinto
perché è stato un indizio sono i tasti
la playstation per quadrate il triangolo
italiana
beh qui tante cerca d'europa
con scarsi come al solito ho fatto con
un giorno hanno distrutto la vetrata una
roba decidente mara che ha sottratto
solo io cercate sia pietro altri
traguardi tutti a praga quasi una
cassaforte del triangolo vale 3
eva
esci da questo corda non mi hanno
raccontato la luce
non è che non dover fare
niente
sono di strane come di quadri nessuno ha
guardato vabbè però peso
no
io sto male si no
sapevo letame
[Musica]
non avete tirato fuori un cavolo con
quel telefono con un ragazzo pronto a
ordinare una pizza alla diavola il
cerchio da qualche parte
vedremo
ma io sono quello che si nota
[Musica]
moda 5 per sette già aperto
io non aviatore non ho giocato bene si
strappa
vuoi che ti accende la luce entra nella
stanza e chiudi ti questa porta alle
spalle
e giusto grazie ai perdenti
ma chi è che mi ha fatto questa roba ma
poi sparito ma c'è un potere quello
sparisce nulla sparito e ti fermi subito
[Musica]
a questo ingegneria ha fatto sempre poco
tempo ha capito se qualcuno piccoli
[Musica]
che cosa ha detto che quella della tua
stanza più che una macchina una macchina
da scrivere una macchina da leggere
leggere tutto d un pezzo di cazzo
ma in più perché devo andare sempre io
per primo proprio come fa anche un po di
john booth soldati dico che questo una
parte quella per il dettaglio è
bruttissimo e ce l'abbiamo e una croce
con madonna che brutta cosa
ok quindi vuol dire che la parola di
rivedere qualcosa per forza e allora
faieta bellissimo e bellissimo questo
coso 0 contro gaza
voglio subito i ragazzi mancano 16
minuti no no no
fa male
era brutta
[Musica]
quindi parla con una voce satanica al
passo della bibbia era sbagliato quindi
come sud america
non lo so devo arrivarci
[Musica]
lui perché ho capito che dovevo mettere
giù come quelle 5
passando per santa celati 677 g6f ci
sara la coniglietta 35 sono cinque anni
fa cascine
solo
ci credo ci siano fatti crediti
un euro
nell'area che faccio una foto ricordo
[Musica]